this video was made possible by tab for
a cause raise money for charity just by
opening tabs which you were going to do
anyway link in the description in the
wake of the death of George Floyd the
whole country has erupted into protests
and riots but with the charging of the
officer who placed his knee on the neck
of George Floyd for over seven minutes
it really raises more questions than it
actually answers such as what's the
difference between second-degree murder
and third-degree murder and why was the
police officer who had his knee on
George Floyd's neck for over seven
minutes initially charged with
third-degree murder but now recently the
prosecutor has upgraded that to
second-degree murder and what about the
other officers do they face liability
they've been charged with aiding and
abetting what is that and what penalties
can they potentially face as a result
and what would happen if a bystander
stepped in to try and prevent this
tragedy from happening what legal
repercussions would they face let's talk
about it
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer because there are a lot of
legal questions surrounding what's going
on with the officers who were involved
in the death of George Floyd now to
recap as you're probably aware in
Minneapolis an officer named Derek
Shelvin placed his knee on the neck of
George Floyd in the process of
apprehending mr. Floyd while other
officers were nearby now I'm not going
to show the footage of this I'm also
going to refrain for the time being
about opining over whether this act
itself was justifiable police force or
whether it was homicide as of today the
the autopsy reports are coming back and
we're getting more information about
that but I do want to talk about the
actual charges that were levied against
officer Shelvin as part of this
particular incident this is going to be
an ongoing series of videos I'm gonna
try and get them out as quickly as
possible to talk about these really
important legal issues including what
happened in the George Floyd incident
and all of the ensuing actions with the
protests riots looting freedom of speech
whether you can deploy the military
within the United States unfortunately
all of this is on the table I never
thought that would be the case but here
we are so with that background let's
look at the different varieties of
murder that could have been charged and
were in fact charged in this particular
case and why the prosecutor might have
initially charged murder in the third
degree and now have upgraded that to
murder in the second degree as we've
talked about a lot on this channel the
different varieties of murder relate to
the intent associated with the
particular action sometimes the same Act
can be a different crime Ward not a
crime at all depending on the mental
state that someone has and in criminal
law the state of mind is called the mens
rea in other words the guilty mind did
you have the requisite intent for
something to be considered a crime and
in Minnesota you start with the most
heinous homicides that have the most
specific intent requirements and by the
time you get to third-degree murder it
has less specific more
intent requirements and get carries with
it a lighter sentence so let's look at
the first statute murder in the first
degree as defined by Minnesota statute
609 point 185 which states that whoever
does any of the following is guilty of
murder in the first degree and shall be
sentenced to imprisonment for life sub 1
causes the death of a human being with
premeditation and with intent to effect
the death of the person or of another
intends to effect the death of a person
is exactly what it sounds like you
specifically intended that by your
actions you would bring about the death
of another person you intended that
specific result that's called specific
intent the premeditation is just
slightly a little bit different than
that it requires some planning ahead of
time we tend to think of premeditation
as lying in wait and just waiting for
someone to come by planning your murder
a sniper on a roof and those certainly
qualify as premeditation and it
certainly qualifies as murder in the
first degree
but premeditation can come about in an
instant if you have that specific intent
to not only hurt someone but to cause
their actual death that is murder in the
first degree and under Minnesota law you
get life in prison people have
speculated that potentially this police
officer might have interacted with mr.
Floyd prior to this incident if that
were the case and this police officer
premeditated and pre-planned a murder of
George Floyd well then that could give
rise to murder in the first degree but
that seems incredibly unlikely you have
to imagine that most police officers
aren't walking around with an axe to
grind and they're just trying to do
their jobs I know it might be hard to
give the benefit of the doubt but I
think in this case that probably applies
so let's assume that murder in the first
degree is off the table even if it's
true it would probably be too hard to
prove and so now that takes us to the
now famous or infamous murder in the
third degree statute in Minnesota
statute six oh nine point one nine five
which states that whoever without intent
to effect the death of any person causes
the death of another person by
perpetrating and act eminently dangerous
to others and evincing a depraved mind
without regard for human life is guilty
of murder in the third degree and may be
sentenced to imprisonment for not more
than 25 years so murder in the third
degree
now lacks any space
intent requirement at all it simply says
that someone did something incredibly
dangerous or stupid and really really
should have known better that these acts
could cause the death of another person
I won't go into the long tortured
history of what a depraved mind is it's
a concept that goes back to Old English
common law but for the sake of argument
this is something that is not
necessarily specifically intended let's
say it's a person who did not intend for
someone to die but the actions were so
depraved that it was very possible that
someone could have died as a result so
this is something that's a lot worse
than mere negligence where the question
is what a reasonable person have done
this particular thing but it's a lot
less than first and second-degree murder
where you have to specifically intend to
have killed the person in question I
think an example of this would be if you
were making a bomb in your own house and
the bomb went off you survived but it
killed a family member who happened to
be in the house you'd probably be
charged with third-degree murder because
you probably didn't intend to kill a
member of your family
but it's so reckless to have been
building bombs in the first place that
you should have known better you didn't
care about the sanctity of human life
and therefore you'll probably be guilty
of third-degree murder as a result of
that even though you never specifically
intended for anyone to be hurt or died
so that takes us to murder in the second
degree which you will not be surprised
has a slightly less onerous intent
requirement if you look at Minnesota
statute six or 9.19
murder in the second degree it says that
whoever does either of the following is
guilty of murder in the second degree
and may be sentenced to imprisonment for
not more than forty years sub one causes
the death of a human being with intent
to effect the death of that person or
another but without premeditation
so really second-degree murder at least
in Minnesota is very similar to
first-degree murder except you lack the
premeditation so you did in the instant
want to bring about the death or great
bodily harm of another person but you
didn't necessarily have a plan ahead of
time he didn't premeditate that
particular crime he didn't premeditate
the the fact that you were going to
murder that person often this can be
seen in firing wantonly into a crowd
in fact I won't go into it but in this
particular statute in Minnesota it
specifically says that if you commit a
drive-by shooting that that qualifies as
second-degree murder so word to the wise
you can't get out of a second-degree
murder charge by firing into a crowd
from a car claiming that you never
intended these specific death of any one
of those people that would still give
rise to a second-degree murder charge in
Minnesota
hey legal eagles it's Devin from the
future I want to amend and update this
particular video because the the first
video that you have been watching is a
combination of clips that I shot before
and after the Attorney General of
Minnesota upgraded the charges against
former officer Chavan now I cover the
felony murder rule in a in a second and
the section that deals with the other
officers who were charged but part of
the analysis regarding second-degree
murder made it seem like Calvin was
charged with traditional second degree
murder as opposed to felony murder
because in Minnesota the felony murder
rule is wrapped up in the second degree
murder charge it is both the traditional
homicide where you have the specific
intent and also the kind of homicide
where you don't have specific intent
because of a felony murder rule and
because it's a combination of clips from
different times it made it seem like
Javon was charged with the traditional
form of second-degree murder when in
fact I was merely trying to explain what
that general type of murder constitutes
but in reality a officer Chavan was
charged with felony murder which I'll
talk about and explain
I received some comments from viewers
that that were confused by that so I
greatly apologize for that confusion
there's a lot of news going on and in an
effort to try and get things out quickly
sometimes things like this are not
explained in the kind of detail that
they probably should so the issue here
is that the Minnesota statute on second
degree murder contains both the
traditional specific intent required
second-degree murder and also what's
called an intentional killing where a
death occurs during the course of
another felony here it seems the
Attorney General is
arguing that Officer Chavan was engaged
in potentially some sort of assault
which constituted a felony and during
the course of that felony
George Floyd died thus he was engaged in
a felony a dangerous felony and someone
died therefore that meets the
requirements of the felony murder rule
which we've talked about doesn't require
specific intent to commit the murder
it requires specific intent to create
the underlying felony in this case it
would be probably some sort of assault
that's sort of an issue because there is
there's this doctrine called the merger
doctrine where in most jurisdictions
that have felony murder you can't use
the underlying crime that has basically
the same elements as the death itself to
form the basis for for the felony murder
rule because you can imagine that the
exception would swallow the rule where
if you engaged in any kind of dangerous
felony that would automatically be
upgraded to a murder because the felony
murder rule kicks in so most
jurisdictions have this merger doctrine
that prevents this sort of upgraded
charge because sometimes just because
someone dies as a result of a felony
being committed at the same time when
it's exactly the same as the killing
itself it doesn't necessarily make sense
that's why you have other things like
murder in the third degree or
manslaughter that generally cover
unintentional killings but Minnesota
doesn't have this merger doctrine which
allows prosecutors to have a discretion
to upgrade the charge for an
unintentional killing up to the status
of murder in the second degree now
whether that is a good thing or a bad
thing is a policy decision that I'll
leave up to you especially under these
circumstances so so I'm sorry I caused
confusion with the first version of this
video I should have gone into more
detail about the felony murder rule and
I'll try to do better in the future
back to the original video so now that
you know the difference between first
second and third degree murder it's
impossible to overlook the elephant in
the room here which is that when you
have an officer-involved death it's
really really hard to prove intent it's
hard to prove intent for any defendant
let alone a police officer as we've
talked about the burden
proof to convict someone of first or
second degree murder is very very high
remember we have a reasonable doubt
standard here so that's the highest
burden in all of criminal law and when
you are saying that someone is guilty of
first-degree murder you have to prove
not only the specific intent that they
intended to kill the person at issue but
also that they had planned it ahead of
time a prosecutor does have discretion
to include what are called lesser
included offenses so if you decided to
charge someone with murder in the first
degree you could also charge them at the
same time with murder in the second
degree and murder in the third degree
and then the jury then gets to choose
which of those three particular offenses
they get to ultimately decide on
sometimes you might not charge the
highest possible crime because it's
gonna be harder to convict with the jury
a phenomenon that you often see with
juries is that if they refuse to convict
on the highest charge sometimes that
bleeds over until they get to either
very low lesser included charge or no
charge at all so there's an art for
prosecutors to choosing the right charge
to go with and sometimes you only want
that one charge so that you don't give
the jury the flexibility to be able to
choose from this whole menu of lesser
included charges and not only that but
when you make the premeditation and the
specific intent requirement of some of
the included charges lack of intent then
becomes relevant the defense is allowed
to bring in that evidence to say this
officer did not have this premeditation
this officer did not have this specific
intent you wouldn't want that to happen
as a prosecutor because it can have
repercussions in terms of the evidence
that actually comes in at trial it kind
of bleeds over the jury hears that he
didn't have these kinds of intent and
while they shouldn't consider that with
respect to some of those lesser included
charges they tend to do that especially
when you have an officer who often gets
the benefit of the doubt that they were
just doing their job so if you're the
prosecutor and you omit first and
second-degree murder then the defense is
not able to bring in evidence that would
be relevant to rebut those specific
intent requirements there's often a big
difference between the highest possible
charge of the prosecutor can bring and
the charge that the prosecutor is most
likely to get
from and even though it's no solace to
the family of George Floyd and no solace
to the people who are out protesting the
charges that were brought against former
officer Chavan here came very very
quickly it's really the exception rather
than the rule that number one charges
are brought against officer in the first
place and number two they're brought as
quickly as they are I will say though
that I strongly disagree with a theory
that is circulating on the internet that
has been bolstered by Harvard Law
Professor Lawrence tribe who was very
critical of the third-degree murder
charge and he wrote in The Boston Globe
recently more critically anyone steeped
in Minnesota law would recognize that a
third degree murder charge would likely
be summarily dismissed for the ironic
reason that Chavan clearly aimed his axe
at Floyd such a miscarriage of justice
would surely trigger still more chaos
and violence I really think professor
tribe gets this wrong here if you have
the requisite mental state for murder in
the first degree or murder in the second
degree you can accurately be charged
with murder in the third degree just
because you have more than the requisite
mens rea it doesn't mean that you get to
get off scot-free of the the lesser
charges and if the prosecutor only
brings a charge of murder in the third
degree that's not going to be dismissed
because you had a worse mental state
than what was required for murder in the
third degree that's just not how that
works so we've talked about former
officer Chavan in particular let's talk
about the potentially three or more
other police officers who are nearby do
they face potential criminal
consequences and the answer is maybe the
first question that I received over
Twitter was Candida guilty of felony
murder I really think that that is
incredibly unlikely felony murder is
something that happens when you have
people who agree to engage in a specific
crime and during the course of that
crime someone dies and when it happens
all of the co-conspirators are guilty of
felony murder not just the person who
pulls the trigger or uses the knife here
it would be very very difficult probably
impossible to prove that the police in
question here all conspired to conduct
some crime so it's very unlikely that
the felony murder rule comes into play
actually except there is one way
that it might you can imagine a scenario
and I don't know if this is factually
correct or not we're all four of these
officers agree or have an understanding
that let's say they're just gonna rough
up a suspect as the president asks law
enforcement to do and then during the
course of that crime
that suspect happens to die then all
four of those officers could in fact be
guilty of second-degree murder felony
murder under Minnesota law but that's
also not really necessary here because
as we've seen the Minnesota District
Attorney charged the other three
officers with aiding and abetting so
whereas the felony murder rule kicks in
where everyone has agreed to commit this
this dangerous felony aiding and
abetting happens commensurate with the
crime with no premeditation or you can
be an accessory to a crime it happens
later now the requirements for aiding
and abetting are pretty simple
one is that a crime was committed which
in this case would be the murder of
George Floyd the second is that the
accused in this case the other officers
intentionally aided counseled or induced
that person to commit the crime the
accused acted with the intent to
facilitate the crime and the accused
acted before the crime was completed so
there are really two crucial questions
here one is did any of these officers
take an affirmative act to help officer
Chavan and the other is did they do it
with the intent to help the crime being
committed that is not an easy thing to
prove especially if you have officers
who are merely standing by refusing to
render aid is not the same thing as
taking an affirmative act with the
intent to facilitate the initial crime
and then you're faced with a question of
did they have a duty to act to prevent
the death in the United States generally
speaking people don't have a duty to
intervene affirmatively to stop an
injustice from happening
the counter-argument would be that they
might be guilty of manslaughter perhaps
in the first or second degree where in
Minnesota you caused the death of
another person by what's called culpable
negligence whereby the person creates an
unreasonable risk and conscientiously
takes chances
of causing death or great bodily harm to
another so again it would be a question
of whether they created the risk itself
I don't know if there is a specific law
that would require them to actively
intervene generally speaking there isn't
one so unless a prosecutor can show a
specific act that they took that made
things worse or created the situation
itself the other officers are probably
not going to face criminal repercussions
and then similarly there is the concept
of being an accessory after the fact and
that happens where the accused assists
the person with the specific purpose to
design or hinder or prevent that
person's apprehension trial or
punishment so again if they took a
specific act with the intent to hinder
that person in this case a former
officer Chavan from being prosecuted
then they would be an accessory after
the fact and then finally the question I
got dozens of dozens of times on Twitter
could a Good Samaritan intervene to say
push the officer off of George Floyd to
prevent the injustice from from
happening and I think the answer to that
is probably not we have laws that
prevent people from interfering with
police officers jobs you have
obstruction of justice even when the
police are perpetrating something that
is manifestly unjust still can't
effectively assault and batter a police
officer so my advice to most people
hashtag not legal advice is do what the
people did here take out your cell phone
video record everything it's really been
a huge boon I think to society the fact
that everyone has a video camera in
their pocket and it reveals the kind of
injustice that's going on on an everyday
basis and we just saw as of today that
I'm recording this video that the Chief
of Police for Louisville was fired
because two police officers who were
involved in a shooting had not activated
their body cameras I think body cameras
should be required on all police I don't
really understand the arguments against
I'm sorry - laughs into opinion here but
we can't rely on the police to police
themselves and I really think that the
most important thing that anyone can do
is to just record injustice whenever you
see it and publish it that is
the best that you can do without getting
into legal trouble yourself and I think
that it's done a lot of good and it will
continue to do a lot of good it's been
incredibly difficult to watch the videos
that have come out recently whether it's
George Floyd whether it's Ahmad our
burry or whether it's the protests it's
really easy to get sucked into the
thinking that we're all helpless and if
there's nothing that we can do but if
you want to do some good in this world I
would recommend a charity that I work
with called tab for a Cause which allows
you to raise money for charity just by
opening up tabs in your browser and
surfing the internet which you were
probably gonna do anyway tempura cause
is a browser extension that allows you
to pick a charity of your choice and
then every time you open up a new tab
instead of a blank page it displays a
beautiful new customisable tab with a
couple of tiny ads and the money that
you generate through those ads is
donated to the charity of your choice
and you can see in real time how much
money is being generated it's gamified
so that every time you open up a new tab
you create a heart which then you can
donate to the charity of your choice
tab for a cause users like you have
raised over nine hundred thousand
dollars so just click the link in the
description to download tab for a cause
and download the extension it's
literally the least that we can possibly
do and you can do some good by doing
what you were going to do anyway so do
you agree with my analysis do you think
the prosecutor should have stayed with
murder three or gone to murder to leave
your objections in the comments and
check out this playlist over here with
all of my other real law reviews where I
talk about all of the crazy things that
are happening in the news today